[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing salazar slytherin
godric gryffindor rowena ravenclaw helga
hufflepuff
and hogwarts more specifically we're
going to be discussing
the founding of hogwarts as well as what
led
to salazar slytherin the founder of
slytherin house
vacating the school hogwarts was founded
when four
10th century witches and wizards got
together and decided that they had
in the sorting hat's own words the
self-same yearning to make the world's
best
magic school thus hogwarts was born
the school itself was built hidden off
somewhere in the scottish highlands
the exact location is never actually
revealed and this was because the 10th
century was a time of hardship for
witches and wizards
during this time every day witches and
wizards were being persecuted by muggles
who were intensely hostile when it came
to witnessing sources of magic
in order to further protect the staff
students and school itself
additional precautions were made in the
form of charms helping to further
conceal the school from muggle
trespasses
after the founders who are close friends
i should add
founded the school they decided that
they would each create and head
their own house which would represent a
personality trait
and skill that they wanted to nurture
and it just so happened that
despite being close friends each founder
happened to value
very different things which created
quite an interesting and
diverse array of students at the school
gryffindor students embodied bravery and
chivalry
ravenclaw intelligence and wit
hufflepuff
loyalty and fair play and slytherin the
values of being sly
and cunning for years the hogwarts
founders
served as head of their respective
houses and sorted students into their
houses
manually however it eventually occurred
to them that they wouldn't be around
forever
and so the sorting hat was born the
creation of the sorting hat certainly
made the lives of the founders much
easier
but it also couldn't have come at a
better time for you see
gryffindor and salazar began to have a
falling out
we know that after they're falling out
salazar ends up leaving the school
but what happened exactly in chapter 11
of the order of the phoenix the sorting
hat
gives us a few more details and never
did they dream that they
might someday be divided for were there
such friends anywhere
as slytherin and gryffindor unless it
was the second pair of hufflepuff and
ravenclaw so how could it have gone so
wrong
how could such friendships fail why i
was there
and so can tell the whole sad sorry tale
all that the sorting hat seems to
introduce in this first segment is that
a
slytherin and gryffindor were previously
the closest of friends
were there such friends anywhere and b
that
something caused the friendship to go
wrong to fail
let's continue so hogwarts worked in
harmony
for several happy years but then discord
crept among us
feeding on our faults and fears the
houses that
like pillars for had once held up our
school
now turned upon each other and divided
sought to rule
and for a while it seemed the school
must meet an early end
what were dueling and with fighting and
the clash of friend on friend
and at last there came a morning when
old southern departed
and though the fighting then died out he
left us quite
down-hearted this second segment speaks
of a short-lived but harmonious time
when friendships were intact and things
flowed seamlessly
however the hat then goes on to divulge
information
about growing tensions regarding the
four houses and the walls that went up
between these houses it seems to suggest
that
when the relationships of the founders
became more tumultuous
a bigger and bigger divide was placed
between the four houses
which resulted in a battle for control
the hat
then alludes to fighting and dueling
between friends
and eventually the departure of sutherin
from the context that the hat has given
us it seems as though the departure of
slytherin stopped the fighting
but certainly didn't raise spirits i
think that
what it ultimately comes down to is
their perspective on muggles
like i mentioned in the beginning during
this time period the tension between
muckles and was it kind was immense
dumbledore comments on this in his copy
of the wizard and the hopping pot
a short story written by beetle the bard
that focuses on wizarding
muggle relations as the witch hunts grew
ever fiercer
wizarding families began to live double
lives using charms of concealment
to protect themselves and their families
by the 17th century
any witch or wizard who chose to
fracturing with muggles became suspect
even an outcast in his or her own
community
what this tells us is that preceding the
17th century
the world was very much wide open the
presence of witches and wizards was well
known to muggles
and did muggles welcome them into their
society
no they hunted them down and this is
what effectively coined the term
witch hunt they didn't praise them for
their magical ability
and welcomed them with open arms they
hunted them down
because they were different because they
were freaks
it wasn't until 1707 when the ministry
of magic was first founded
that the two worlds were finally
separated it's
no secret that southern didn't like
muggles or muggle borns
after all it was him that created the
basilisk and
the chamber of secrets i think that this
is where he strongly disagreed with his
co-founders
godric helge and rowena were all more
progressive in their thinking
being more welcoming of muggles in order
to expedite the assimilation
of the two worlds however salazar who
saw what muggles did to his people
took the opposite approach and instead
vowed to eliminate them
witches and wizards were hunted down and
burned by muggles
for being freaks and though salazar's
course of action wasn't appropriate
you can probably at least sort of see
where he was coming from
salazar slytherin born right into this
era of oppression
sometime before 976 a.d was birthed into
a world full of hate and conflict
right from childhood he would have been
thrown right into the mix
into witch hunts and hiding fearing for
his life
and so for this reason it's not
surprising that slytherin went down
in the history books as a strong
proponent for having only pure blood
students at the school
his legacy was ultimately passed on to
the other southerners of the school
who adopted this same attitude which
isn't surprising
given how the sorting hat works where
slithering chose vengeance
the other founders chose a moral high
ground they were the bigger people
likely because of how muggles had
treated wizardkind he fundamentally felt
that muggleborns were unworthy of
studying magic
something which gryffindor founder
godric gryffindor strongly opposed
a differing stance on how to deal with
the impression of your people
is certainly a divisive topic and i
believe that it's ultimately what
led to salazar leaving the school for
good i think that
deep down salazar and godric were still
good friends
they just couldn't find mutual ground on
this extremely
important topic i think that one thing
that was perpetuated however
was the emphasis placed on respecting
that each world was very different
for as long as we've known hogwarts
which is the primary introduction to the
wizarding world for muggleborns
seems to place a huge emphasis on the
importance of the divide between the two
worlds
and i think that this is for good reason
they're taught very early on
they are two completely different places
and need to be treated
as such you can't bring muggle values
into the wizarding world
in the same way that you can't bring
wizarding values into the muggle world
what do you guys think did you know
about all of this
let me know in the comments section
below if you enjoy the content please
like the video
and subscribe to the channel until next
time
it does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget
to live
you